Magnus we've got this position set up
does it look familiar at all
I think I saw it on a social media post
earlier today or something similar
but do you know which game this is from
yeah it's uh from Ronaldo against Messi
or that's or very similar only the color
complex has changed a little bit but the
original uh my game against Nakamura
from nowhere chess 2017.
um very tumultuous event for me I ended
up with -1 and at several points during
the tournament was I in risk of dropping
to number two or three or even four in
the world so it was tough which is why
you remember it so well
when you spotted this on Twitter today
did you immediately realize which game
this is no I I saw Peter Heinz tweets
and then I
then I I got the connection but I saw
his tweet before I saw the Ronaldo mess
with him
it's been Messi and Ronaldo from a game
between you and Hikaru try to say Messi
Ronaldo comparison with you and Hikaru
Australia but uh
but
um
um yeah I mean he's good at a lot of the
stuff that I'm good at uh for sure so
it's not it's not the worst comparison
in the world
Ronaldo decided to be white here you
were white in your game uh were you glad
with that that it was Ronaldo playing
with the white pieces and not messy for
this picture
I would have been okay with both all
right now we have it Magnus recognizing
the game Hikaru versus Magnus from
Norway 2017. yeah rather